All right.
So some of you might know that I just quit my data science job at Fang.
The reason why I not seeing explicitly which company it's in case I
need to go begging back from my job, you know?
And I don't want them to say like, Oh my God,
what did you say this about a company. We're not going to take you back now,
before I go into why I quit my job,
I kind of have to re-explain what my role was as the data scientist and the
reason why I have to re-explain it is because, um,
it's not as standardized as like software engineering, which is, I mean, I,
I know I explained in a lot of videos, but I'm just going to do it again,
just so that you can have, uh, the right context to understand why quit.
So basically this was my job title at
this company and, um, yeah, so you can read it. So, in essence,
in my words, um,
a data scientist is usually put into a product team and usually in the product
team, there's a product manager, there are software engineers,
and there's a data scientist. Now, obviously there are other roles, you know,
for example, like UX researchers and, um,
and like product specialist, marketing people, legal people and stuff like that.
But I'm just going to simplify it and say, okay,
so there's software engineers and data scientists and product managers.
So I'm not going to explain it in a way where it's like, Oh, data scientists,
they make mottos. They use like AR and like software engineers,
they built infrastructure and to use programming languages, blah, blah, blah.
I'm not going to explain like that.
I'm going to explain it in a more fundamental way of what their roles actually
are. So engineers,
they actually have the technical abilities to build the thing.
We actually want to build product managers.
They're basically the leaders or like the owners of the product.
They decide what the product is going to do,
and also what the product should be doing.
Basically they have the vision and they're in charge of actually executing,
getting the done. And, um, you know,
they'll do whatever they need to do to actually ship a product.
In some ways you could think of them as like mini CEOs of a product or a
feature. And then data scientists.
We have the most time to think because we don't need to like build anything
like for engineers and stuff like that.
And we also don't need to focus on executing and talking to cross-functional
partners all the time. So in some ways,
because we're able to think more than those two counterparts,
where basically like advisors are like consultants of like the product.
We don't actually make the final decisions and calls. I mean,
obviously your opinions matter. But in, in essence,
the people who had the final say are kind of the product managers and also the
engineers,
because the engineers are going to build it so they could build whatever they
want and then product managers. Um, they're the ones,
they're the ones that decide on the future of the product now,
because we have so much time to think our job is to try to understand
the product inside the now we're a support, technically not.
I'm not saying all data scientists do that,
but I think that the fundamental role of a data scientist is to understand the
product in and out better than anyone else. The reason is because, like I said,
you have more time to think you have more time in your hand.
So basically we use data to try to understand exactly what the product needs and
where the product should go in terms of the product direction.
And what we can do is we can tell our team exactly where we should prioritize
and how we should do certain things. Why?
Because we have so much time to think about it. You know,
we don't need to build stuff. We don't need to execute on anything.
So that's our role.
We're always making sure that the team is working on the most important things
currently. Okay. I'll do one more analogy just because I like doing analogies.
So imagine the YouTube channel, right. Um, uh,
engineers would be like video producers,
which is the people who actually know how to make videos because Indiana,
if you don't have a video, you're not going to have a video channel.
So I think of engineers like video producers, and then product managers,
I think of product managers as, um,
the people who it doesn't need to be multiple people.
It could just be one person,
but basically the person who sends emails tries to look for sponsorships and
they think about, okay, where should this channel go? Basically,
they do everything. That's not relate to videos. You know, we got branding,
we got sending emails, making websites, communicating with other YouTubers,
basically just all the crap that video producers might not want to do.
So I think those people are like the product managers,
and then we got a data science. So data scientists would be kind of like an, uh,
an analyst of your YouTube channel. Uh,
what an Alice would do is they would all,
they always look at analytics to make sure that, uh, you know,
you get some insights to know what kind of videos to make next. Like,
for example, you look at the views and they say like, Oh, okay, you know,
these things are kind of hot right now, or this is kind of trending.
And you look at comments to basically, you're like,
you're trying to understand your users the best way you can using data or
anything. Actually, it doesn't even matter. It doesn't even need to be data.
So basically those are the fundamental rows.
Basically a data scientist should figure out how to get more subscribers,
how to get more views.
And why are certain things working or are certain things not working.
So then give them insights, give, uh,
the product manager or like the video producer insights into like, okay,
what should you make next? How should we, you know, like these strategies? Okay.
I know that was kind of long just to explain fundamentally what a data science.
This is need water.
Okay. I'm too lazy to get water. Okay. But, um,
basically the reason why I quit my data science job.
In essence, it's because.
Cause I'm still exploring.
So I guess what I'm trying to say is a lot of people are content with their
first job out of college. And um, for my case,
I think that for the first years out of your college,
it is totally okay to keep searching and try to understand yourself and
try to understand what exactly is a right fit for you in terms of a job.
Like I prioritize, well, I might be wrong. I don't know,
but I prioritize long-term like, for example,
if I just stuck with data scientists and in the future,
I realized that I hate the job.
Then the cost of switching jobs is a lot higher later on if I was already five
years or six years in.
So I do think that sacrificing the first few years,
trying to discover what you actually want is definitely beneficial for your
career. Hopefully I don't know. We'll see. So I'm not saying, Oh, by the way,
I'm switching to software engineering.
I have a feeling that some people don't know,
but I'm not saying that software engineering is my true calling or that this is
the final job that I want. I don't know. I'm not sure I might be wrong.
You know, I might not even last for like another year or two,
but in the current state that I am right now,
I feel that I don't want to do, you know, the analytics part, like,
you know, the YouTube guy where he just looks at analytics,
I kind of want to make videos. I want to be a video producer.
So in this analogy, it means that I want to build things.
And I think that's currently what I want, at least why I think I want,
so that's why I'm going to try out software engineering now. And uh,
yeah. Cause I thought that I was always a builder and you know,
I do like some aspects of data scientists, but you know,
I want to try to build stuff this time. Like I think at the core,
my personality does fit more of a builder. You know, I do like building stuff,
but yeah. So yeah,
so those are the arguments of me wanting to become a software engineer.
So I'm going to talk about some things about why I don't want to be a data
scientist anymore.
So at least at my company or my old company,
the way you get evaluated,
no matter what role you have is how much impact you have.
And basically what impact means is it, do you,
did you have like a positive contribution to the company?
So even if you worked your off or you did, you know, you do a lot of smart,
intelligent things,
but it doesn't have any positive impact to the company or like it doesn't really
change anything. Then you still might get fired after awhile.
So as a data scientist using the scope that I talked about,
like the fundamental rows, basically, um, how it,
data scientists can have impact in a company like that is by, uh,
make like being like influencing the product decision, uh,
influencing the product direction.
So for a data scientist using that scope of like fundamental rows, uh,
data scientists, how they can have impact is by, you know,
making it analysis or something such that it leads into
actionable insight,
meaning that people will use that insight and now they'll take action to towards
it and then it will benefit the company. So that's impact. All right.
So I have a few examples.
I'm just going to read it out loud because I can't remember them.
So basically in a simple way,
if your analysis convinced the engineers to build something and our metrics went
up,
that's impact also if your analysis convinced a PM and the team
to put a new feature a or a project on the roadmap that's
impact,
if you create an amazing prediction algorithm to predict whether a user
watched a video with a loan in their apartment or with friends,
but the team didn't decide to implement it because they don't think it's useful.
That is not impact.
If you found that Korea is a growing market for live videos,
and you have tons of evidence that adding a donation button can make your
company dominant in the live video market in, uh, in Korea.
But even with their sound evidence,
you cannot convince your product team to focus on Korea. That is not impact.
So as you can see,
it's not always a hundred percent fair because for some team it might be
easier than another.
And there's a lot of factor that plays into the success of a data scientist and
some of them are out of your control.
And that was one thing that I found a little bit harder to cope with.
Now I've worked with teams where it was really,
really easy to find opportunities,
and then you show those opportunities to them and then they're super excited and
they'll do it, you know, and that's a lot of impact,
but I've also worked for teams that move a lot
slower, I guess, a more friction. And basically, you know,
you don't have as much credibility to them and it's a lot more difficult to
convince them to do what you want to do. So that's why it's a little bit harder.
So, and basically if you have no influence,
you don't have impact as a data scientist. Now,
sometimes you might be lucky that your work is so good that your work speaks for
itself, right? But the reality is that in life, that's not always the case.
Sometimes you just have to be influential.
Basically you have to have the skills to influence your peers,
your engineering manager, the product manager.
You have to get them in the same team as you,
or you have to basically are basically,
you have to kind of convince them that your ideas are good and that they should
implement it. But that's the thing. Um, it doesn't always happen.
And sometimes you gotta be pretty good at like the office politics or like,
you know, stuff that are more like soft skills ish. And I believe those are,
were the skills that lacked or at least that's what I thought before.
And which made me kind of like, eh, like believe it or not,
I'm actually kind of like a work introvert.
So I'm also like still very inexperience in, in, in,
uh, understanding like the work dynamics and also like some office politics and
stuff like that. I'm still quite new. So I mean, I did get better,
but at the time that was what made me want to switch to software engineering
because I felt like I wasn't ready to be a product leader on my team.
I didn't feel like I had the maturity to make an influence decisions on my team.
I didn't have the confidence in myself nor my work and that stressed
me out. Yeah. That's stressed me out now don't get me wrong.
There's a lot of aspects of data science that I enjoyed and that I like and that
I still like. And I do hope that when I work as a sweep,
that I could use some of the things that I've learned and,
and use it as my advantage, but basically how I think about it.
Like my philosophy is that your goal shouldn't be like, Oh, I should be really,
uh,
I should be a really good data scientist or I should be a really good software
engineer. You should be the ultimate worker. Okay. That sounds kind of, we are.
But basically what I'm trying to say is you want to be the guy who can solve
everything with anything, right? Like if there's a problem,
you're the guy to solve it. No matter if it's a technical problem,
a business problem, or like an analytics problem and stuff like that,
you want to be the guy that people can depend on.
And that's the person that I'm trying to beat.
And for now the skills I want to work on or, you know, building skills,
like a software engineer. So yeah. I mean, I haven't done that in ages.
I kind of miss it. Okay. So now what, you know, what am I doing now? Well,
I am unaware employed.
So basically what I do is every day I just sit on my and I work on interview
problems. What else have I been doing? Yeah. So, you know,
because I have so much time in mind, Hans, um,
I've been going to blind a lot, uh, blindness this like anonymous, uh,
forum app that you can check, uh, you can check like gossip.
So basically when I worked at like my company X,
what I could have done is I could have gone to blind and see what other people
were talking about that also worked at company X. So basically lots of gossip,
but I also use it for non gossip.
And there's a lot of stuff that you can read about in like normal topics where,
uh, just bunch of people from Silicon Valley, they just talk about random stuff.
And most of the time they talk about, you know, switching company,
interviewing ed or TC, total compensation, how much they make.
It's a good way for me to get a feel of what the market is like right now.
So I use it a lot, almost obsessively. A lot of times I check like, okay,
you know, um, you know,
a company X interview process to kind of get a feel of like how they interview
you. So that's why I do, I mean, you guys should totally check it out.
It's pretty cool. Um, yeah. Lots of, uh, lots of anonymous, uh, star.
Yeah. So basically, um, you know, I,
I get a lot of questions sometimes from people saying like, Oh,
how should I do X or where, what should I do to find X, Y or whatever? Oh, wait,
my Canada's almost done. Yeah. So pretty much like, um,
I get a lot of questions where sometimes I'd over know the answer,
but how do I get the answers? Uh, you know, I can go to Google. I go to,
you know, I'll go expert to learn some stuff.
I'd use blind to understand how to interview process are. Like,
I use a lot of these websites. So I feel like, you know,
instead of me answering all the questions for you guys,
I should just give you the tool to answer these questions, right?
So there's this quote, you know what they say,
give a man a fish and you feed him for a day, teach a man how to use blind,
and then we'll get into a career and buy organic fish from whole foods for a
lifetime. All right. That's all I have to say for today.
Thanks for watching peace.
[Inaudible].